dijon cité des ducs de bourgogne est une
ville moderne où l'homme a pris ses
aises au détriment souvent de la nature
pourtant en son centre se cache un îlot
de verdure et de calme
le jardin des sciences au jardin de
l'arquebusé un espace remarquable dont
peuvent profiter au fil des saisons les
amoureux des plantes
c'est également un lieu d'études et
d'expérimentations qui mène de multiples
actions pour redonner à la nature sa
place dans la ville ce travail est mené
par différents acteurs du jardin dont
gérard ferrière le directeur j'ai
l'impression pour les gants pour la vie
de façon générale j'ai appris l'alphabet
en regardant fleurir le défi
les plantes c'est le domaine de jeunes
allemands ce botaniste se partage entre
les herbiers conservées dans les
réserves et les collectes sur le terrain
à botanique c'est une passion qui vous
prend aux tripes et vous ne pouvez pas
prendre tous les jours en observant et
plus vous observez plus vous découvrirez
puis c'est passé vent
pas de plantes sans insectes c'est le
domaine de l'entomologiste stéphane
puissant qui vaille sur une des plus
belles collections de france le jardin
des sciences est aussi à l'initiative
d'intervention auprès du public
nous suivrons cyril anglais venu
prodiguer quelques conseils dans un
jardin partagé
animée par hélène planckaert pour la
peau c'est un premier contact qui crée
notamment effectivement grâce à la dette
parce que ce ça qui attire les gens
agnès bougeront enfin nous fera
découvrir les projets réalisés par des
enfants grâce au jardin des sciences sur
le thème de la biodiversité
mais c'est ferrière un hippopotame est
un éléphant au mieux du jardin des
sciences s'est elle même pas connu
pourquoi sont-ils là c'est non c'est une
caravane extraordinaire comme le jardin
également et extraordinaire le jardin
des sciences est consacrée aux rives ans
et ceux vivant c'est une longue histoire
nous leur racontons ici au muséum est
également dans un planétarium et jardin
botanique le muséum a été fondée à la
révolution française à partir de
collection l'histoire naturelle qui
existe est justement en bourgogne est un
peu partout en france
puis progressivement enrichi par des
trois expéditions dans le monde entier
ce bâtiment
le pavillon de la ruse bien avant le
muséum d'histoire naturelle il y avait
des compagnies qui s'aplatit compagnie
des arcs dizier qui s'exerçait au tir
sous ses arcades à l'époque du net et
les cibles étaient cassés au son de
cette grande pluie
d'où le nom jardin aussi de la rigueur
le jardin d'environ trois hectares est
divisé en plusieurs espaces tous
destinés à illustrer un aspect de ce
qu'on appelle la biodiversité
ici c'est l'espèce dédié aux plantes
sauvages dans ses parts à sont présentés
les espèces les plus représentatifs de
la fleur de bourgogne selon la nature du
sol l'altitude le climat parfois ce sont
celles qu'on voit le moins regard de
pauline ces plantes distingue quelque
chose on peut considérer ça comme des
mauvaises herbes
alors je peux faire le mort herbes
folles et pourquoi presque chaque plante
à son gros dans la nature ces herbes
folles justement sert de base aux
chaînes alimentaires et notamment aux
insectes pollinisateurs
ces herbes folles peuvent avoir des
vertus et celle ci regarde quand je
coupe la tige tu vois un super jaulin et
ce subtil et légèrement acide
et on l'utilisait pour brûler les
verrues plus loin le coquelicot que l'on
rencontre au milieu des chants tziganes
et de cette plante on l'a extrait on
continue à le faire justement des
molécules chimiques pour soigner des
maladies c'est car il faut savoir que la
la pénicilline
par exemple un champignon l'aspirine
aussi via d'une plante et chaque année
on découvre de nouvelles molécules plus
d'une centaine pratiquement chaleur
chaque année venant des végétaux ici des
plantes par exemple la datura aussi qui
possèdent des propriétés intéressantes
m'utiliser à toute petite dose ou
ligneuse et une grille et de réserve
elle est très toxique
mais la nature représente une vraie
bibliothèque de molécules
favoriser le retour de la nature dans
une ville cela suppose de savoir d'où
l'on vient et de quoi était fait la
biodiversité autrefois en matière de
végétaux cette mémoire se trouve ici
dans ses réserves au botanique
johan allemand et conservent des
herbiers don le plus précieux lherbier
prince ont fait l'objet de soins aux
patients
c'est terminé c'est un patrimoine
régional c'est pour ça qu'il a été
choisi pour pour cette restauration il
compte à peu près quinze mille cinq
cents planches et donc dans cet herbier
on retrouve toutes les plantes qui
composent la flore de bourgogne donc il
ya un atelier qui a été monté avec des
bénévoles de la société d'histoire
naturelle de bourgogne qui s'est donc à
la restauration s'étaient remis afin
qu'ils soient numérisés et valoriser
dans de bonnes conditions
ça travaille sur plus de 15000 planches
là on en a fait à peu près 7000 bon
c'est un travail de plusieurs années
une par une
chacune de ses planchers décollé de son
support et recoller sur un papier plus
adapté à une conservation de long terme
le but est de garder dans les meilleures
conditions
cette bibliothèque végétal vieille de
plus de deux siècles les réserves compte
également des planches plus récentes
elles sont alimentées régulièrement
grâce aux herbiers constitué par jon
l'allemande vie même continué à récolter
des échantillons pour approvisionner les
collections du muséum donc toi ça c'est
ce qu'elles étaient récoltées l'année
dernière d'accord donc l'intérêt c'est
de compléter notre et aubier donc sur le
territoire du grand dijon donc enfin de
suivre la biodiversité qui s'y
développent les juifs c'est vraiment
d'avoir la feuille lafleur le fruit
voilà rassurés pour assurer une bonne
détermination
or black book dc goff président a donc
là on pourrait dire qu'il manque la
fleur mais non plus car c'est ça ça
c'est des fruits dans les fleuves sont
déjà passés tous d'accord donc il ya
plus calés sur le plateau de la cras
pour réaliser les prélèvements hockey
la fin situé à l'ouest de dijon est un
des terrains de collecte favori du
botaniste une partie de ce plateau
calcaire est la propriété du grand dijon
qu'il a acheté il ya quelques années
pour garder une ceinture verte et éviter
que la ville ne s'étale trop on y trouve
une agriculture périurbaine
essentiellement des céréales et de la
vigne ainsi que des bosquets et des
prairies
donc là on va aller sur un cari que j'ai
déjà observée l'année dernière ça on la
croit droits pour pouvoir faire le suivi
de la plan qui s'y développent
j'imagine que beaucoup d'espèces dans ce
milieu roger dernier j'ai pu observer à
peu près cent dix espèces avait donc en
plusieurs fois
conscient puisqu'il a déclaré tanière
estivale et c'est donc là on va faire un
premier enlevé d'accord là tu as un mail
empire au regard des jeux l'arraché qui
leur est pour garder le calice il est
poli ou pas poilu par le calice c'est
quoi c'est l'ensemble de ses pannes
c'est la partie verte qui met davantage
de voix d'ici voilà c'est pas lui c'est
plus pressants voilà donc pas pouvoir
cocher sur sur le relevé et non un
lecteur all of us ici en bleu c'est le
bide les deux genève a jugé lundi m6 qui
évoluent sur les quatre faces de satish
comme ça qu'on les reconnaît
quai des marques s'en va le ramener au
jardin des sciences sont mal intégrés du
coup on va le faire salle hergé on va
compter une planche derby qui va être
incorporé à l'ére bis qui prêtent du
territoire du grand lyon afin de
connaître l'avis des pays développe donc
on voit que dijon est à proximité
juste à côté donc ce plateau je joue
vraiment un rôle de réservoir de
biodiversité pour ça qu'on tente d'aider
pourquoi des corridors écologiques
n'accorde aucun point là bas donc on va
mettre les petits échantillons sous
presse pour assurer une bonne
disposition une conservation changer les
papiers
dès demain d'accord desséché
un jardin des sciences a également pour
mission de porter la bonne parole
hors de ces murs régulièrement des
animateurs interviennent dans pour
apporter informations conseils et bons
tuyaux
c'est ce que vient faire aujourd'hui
thierry l'anglais dans le jardin partagé
du cèdre bleu dans lé quartier de la
fontaine d'ouche
ici chacun cultive son propre carré
potager et participe à des plantations
collective le lieu est agréable
l'ambiance travailleuses et bonne enfant
mais la bonne volonté a parfois besoin
d'un coup de pouce en l'occurrence les
conseils de thierry l'anglais qui ainsi
mines devient donne un cours de
diversité végétale les personnes sont
vraiment très très solidaires les unes
des autres
c'était ont compris le message compris
le message
d'ailleurs on n'a pas cultivée
uniquement et diamants on essaie
justement de faire débat communautaire
ce qui va permettre justement aux quarts
et individuelles que chacun a le pouvoir
qui le faire des cultures en alternance
est ce que j'expliquais tout à l'heure
en leader
semer repiquer la salade mais si que de
vie d'une salade est très très court
donc ça va vous permettre ensuite
ensuite à un mois après le pouvoir
attaquer sur du n'avait d'autre choix
tout ça c'est des conseils qu'on donne
quand on vient sur les dunes la tétanie
pas votre bac maria moi j'ai courgettes
tomates radis céleri je suis d avis que
vous avez découvert des lieux que vous
connaissez pas ou pas et grâce au jardin
j'ai découvert l'année dernière les
poivrons noir connaît le rouge le vert
le jaune mais avant de coiffer ou violet
mort violer je reconnais c'est fort
c'est important qui a un contact avec la
terre parce que des personnes qui ne
maîtrisent pas forcément la langue
française et du coup l'accès et le lien
concret avec les gens est beaucoup plus
direct parce que du coup à l'objectif de
la personne c'est de faire planter par
exemple sa tomate sa carotte hop ça nous
donne l'occasion de créer un lien et
ensuite de rebondir pourquoi pas de
l'orienter sur un cours de français dans
le cadre de notre structure pour nous
voilà c'est un outil a pour travailler
plein de choses à l'échelle du quartier
on
retour au jardin des sciences une
quarantaine de personnes y travaillent
toute l'année
parmi eux les jardiniers dont la mission
est d'entretenir les espaces à vocation
pédagogique et renouveler en permanence
les bordures en fonction des saisons
pour le plaisir des yeux des visiteurs
parmi les parterres pédagogique il y à
celui dédié aux plantes dites paie-t-il
où sont cultivés plusieurs variétés
d'une même espèce
nous arrivons dans un nouvel espace aqua
celui ci est chez lui c est consacré aux
plantes cultivées
nous les humains on a dû sélectionner
des plantes venant de la nature pour
former de nouvelles variétés ce que les
scientifiques appellent des cultivars
c'est la base de notre alimentation
mais il ya eu des grandes disparition
d'espèces qui touche à la fois sauvages
et cultivées
alors prenons l'exemple des blés
aujourd'hui justement les agriculteurs
sèment à peu près en france simplement
quatre variétés de blé alors qu'il y en
a des dizaines et des dizaines
on pourrait multiplier les exemples en
france on sait à peu près 90% de nos
maïs à partir d'une même variété
génétique à dire qu'on a érodé ce que
l'on appelle la biodiversité et donc y
at il une variété spécifique à la
bourgogne qui est vraiment cliqué les
allées pleines alors
toutes ces variétés justement sont
maintenant recultivée mais tu as raison
en bourgogne on a sélectionné aussi des
végétaux particulier je pense par
exemple à des cornichons aux pruneaux
aussi à des variétés bourguignonne de
cornichons le cornichon
d'après une vie par exemple des chronos
aussi des aspects l'aspergent de
sassenay qui viennent de notre jour
comme vous
non
oh
on
la nature s'est appauvri en ville la
baisse du nombre d'insectes le montre
bien
pour mieux connaître ces populations et
leur évolution
le jardin possède une fabuleuse
collection entomologique une des plus
belles de france avec plus de 600 mille
spécimens du monde entier la grande
majorité locale bien sûr est alimenté en
permanence par stéphane puissant le
maître de ces lieux et monique une
bénévole passionné le docteur abeilles
une belle sauvage une semi un bourgeon
quelques diptères un terme à ce week-end
ça très bien leurs niveaux de
biodiversité y en a pas mal de choses
si vous pouviez aller au filet fauchois
regarder un petit peu ce qu'il ya un
insecte a collecté là aujourd'hui comme
il faut pour ça serait bien
après on pourra regarder comment parler
ce qui sort en même temps en différents
endroits de la ville
l'un des terrains de jeu de ces deux
accrocs petites bêtes c'est bien sûr le
jardin des sciences
mais de façon générale c'est sur tout le
territoire du grand dijon et même au
delà qu'ils font leur chasse aux
insectes afin d'identifier les zones les
plus riches et celles qui sont les plus
fragiles
stéphane je crois que je vais trouver
des petites bêtes pour vous le groupe
peut jamais savoir ça va être des
cicadelles voilà on va
bon ben on va regarder ça allait sortir
du cube les met dans la petite coupelle
alors qu'est ce que nous avons à deux
spécimens
bon il y en a on peut savoir ce que
c'est tout de suite celui qui est rouge
et noir ce qui est rouge et noir ça
c'est un cirque hop c'est très courant
dans la strate herbacée oui c'est ça ça
ces motos hlomador cet homme on ira voir
à collection mais a priori on l'a déjà
par contre l'autre oui un autre ici ça
le plus petit ça c'est 1,6 us voilà oui
c'est ce qui ressemble un petit peu à
des adf par exemple à dire sans équipe a
des papillons
donc il va falloir le mettre sous la
loupe binoculaire parce que il ya
plusieurs espèces et malheureusement on
est obligés de disséquer pour savoir
quelle qu'elle soit c'est précisément on
voit bien la capsule génitales qui
renferme l'ensemble des pièces coppula
trices qui sont caractéristiques de
l'espèce à laquelle il appartient
mon rôle c'est de pouvoir identifier les
espèces patrimoniales la biodiversité de
pouvoir l'évaluer et ainsi d'identifier
des réservoirs de foudre c'est à dire
d'identifier des milieux qui mérite
d'être protégée parce qu'ils abritent
des espèces qui sont devenus rares ou
alors parce qu'elle sait milieu serbe de
continuité écologique dans la dans l'air
pour la reproduction d'espèces menacées
et ces continuités écologiques sont
importantes pour ces espèces parce
qu'elles permettent d'entretenir un
brassage génétique et donc une fiabilité
à long terme de l'espèce
esthétique pédagogique le jardin des
sciences de dijon se veut aussi un
modèle au détour de certaines allées des
espaces en donc été aménagé pour
favoriser la biodiversité et montrer
ainsi aux visiteurs que parfois la
nature se contente des plus terribles au
7/2 maison à côté des cultures au jardin
botanique il ya aussi des habitats c'est
un hôtel est un hôtel trois étoiles
alors pourquoi désastre il faut savoir
que en vingt ans on a perdu à peu près
50% des papillons de nos premiers essais
des ancêtres est justement très
important qui viennent pour ici et
justement se reproduit a donc ici ou
féconder nos légumes nos fruits et doug
à côté on se retrouve face à une crise
qui permet de servir de nourriture pour
qui ces insectes exactement des prairies
fleuries ou des prix écologique est
maintenant à dijon on veut être une
référence écologique on veut se montrer
justement excellent sur la nature et ses
prairies participent au fleurissement
d'une part c'est elles sont peu
exigeants qu justement en qualité du sol
et elle favorise la diversité aussi
sauvage justement notamment des insectes
mais des oiseaux dans une
nous rentrons dans la roseraie consacré
à l'histoire de cette belle semaine
dans l'antiquité déjà il y avait des
rosiers levya romaine était orné de
rosiers
puis tout au cours de l'histoire pour
obtenir des parfums justement des odeurs
des couleurs aussi plus de fois nous les
humains on les a sélectionnés on a
ramené des roses du moyen-orient du
proche orient aussi à une époque 19e
début du xxème ou la rose était à la
mode et dans ces trois oreilles à dire
une rose spécifiques à la région
dijonnaise et bien notamment celle ci
qui s'appelle qui a la prétention
d'échappée gloire de dijon mais tout ce
massif est consacré à des rosiers
justement sélectionné par niveau vision
pour des couleurs pour des formes de
fleurs différents mais gloire de dijon
est une fleur
c'est le prix de la beauté fragile
l'apprentissage de la nature passe aussi
par les changes
le travail en commun avec des publics de
tous types c'est dans ce sens que le
jardin des sciences mène des actions à
destination des enfants
pilotée notamment par agnès rougeron
l'une d'elles est une opération ou des
enfants sur leurs temps périscolaire
réalise des projets scientifiques
aujourd'hui c'est jour de restitution
les enfants viennent présenter leurs
créations
le thème cette année comment améliorer
l'accueil de la nature dans la ville
alors est ce que vous avez réussi à
résister et comment vous avez fait ses
débuts m'a fait penser vidéo donc plus
l'opacité d'un mais ça peut marcher
qu'est ce que vous a émis un signal pour
que ça fonctionne nous sommes le choix
sable fin les a montrés très sont
d'accord le jour nations formant une
mission d'éducation à l'environnement au
développement durable à la nature en
ville et par le biais de tous nos
partenaires on essaie justement comment
appliquer vraiment de manière intense et
profonde les enfants le but c'est
vraiment que les enfants se posent des
questions expérimente c'est finalement
comment en manipulant et bien on peut
construire des dispositifs justement qui
vont favoriser les insectes les
coccinelles les oiseaux et cetera donc
c'est vraiment notre route justement de
susciter l envie d'agir et ce dès le
plus jeune âge nous et vivant de la
diversité végétale de notre planète
jardin des sciences de dijon est un lieu
de détente privilégié pour nombre de
dijonnais
il est aussi un acteur important du
retour de la nature dans la cité des
ducs
grâce aux actions qu'il mène dans et
hors de ses murs il bénéficie depuis
deux ans du prestigieux label eco jardin
m